All strategic leaders face complexity
in their competitive environments.
What you see is enormous variety of
potentially disruptive processes
going on that really exacerbate
the challenges that leaders face.
>> The fundamental
responsibility of the general manager
is to create a strategy, a way his or
her organization is going to achieve
success competing in the world.
And then to build an organization
through which that
strategy can be realized.
>> What they need to do is have a set of
skills for diagnosing the challenges that
they're tackling and also then being able
to translate that into an action plan.
>> What I'd like to do is figure out
how my business unit can contribute
to my company's strategy and
align with my company's long term goals.
>> The main focus of this program
is on the issue of what we call alignment.
How do I align my strategy to
my competitive environment?
And how do I align my
organizational design
to the strategy that I'm trying to pursue.
>> What is the right leadership and
what works and what doesn't work.
>> Great organizations are well-aligned
organizations.
We really bring together faculty
who have devoted their careers
to understanding the kinds of
challenges that lead our space.
>> These are the guys that wrote the cases
and we're in the room with the people
who worked in the companies, so
it's fantastic
>> The innovation in
the world right now is centered
out on Silicon Valley, and
I see Stanford as a hub for that.
>> I think the most exciting part that
many participants benefit from is designed
thinking, that really interactive and
engaged kind of process.
We also have a management simulator
that participants engage in.
Where they really get to understand
the challenges of teamwork and
leadership in a hands-on way that
opens eyes for a lot of people.
Having the opportunity to exchange ideas,
pitch those ideas to other people
will bring new value to our participants.
>> A successful
leadership is not about
a cookie cutter solution.
We really wanted to take you away
from just feeding you at standard
here's what all the best companies do to
saying let's give you the ability to build
your own solution set.
>> Managers
get motivated to create new ideas.
>> Each person came
with different perspectives.
>> The information of this program will
help me become a better leader.
>> Was really well-rounded,
global experience I will
treasure rest of my life.
[MUSIC]